Speaker 1: Let's go next to Nory from
Boston. Nory, you were on the air.
Speaker 4: David Sherbert in New York a few months
ago, but I was curious on one of year and this has
been a couple of weeks now around Mike Pence. Do
you think Trump could kind of save him from the
grave, he put them in and take him back as the VP
like, hey, he betrayed us, but I talked to him.
He's on our side now. He'll do what you do.
Speaker 1: Absolutely you can. All in politics,
you can almost always rescue whoever, even
though Mike Pence has been vilified, you know,
they were chanting Hang Pence. He spoke at some
conservative conference a couple of weeks ago. The
whole crowd booed him. I think that's what you're
referring to. Trump has said things about Mike
Pence. Let us down if and just hypothetically,
if in twenty twenty four Trump ran and he said,
we are bringing back the best vice president
this country has ever had. He did what he
could with the election, but we just didn't have
the rhinos with us. He could completely come up
with some B.S. and say pences the greatest
and rehabilitate his reputation overnight.
Speaker 4: I was stuck between, like, shooty,
try to grab pants or be like, OK, Raun dissenters
work together even though I hate
you because you're the second.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I have no I think that it's too
early to tell. Trump could go either way. You
know, the thing about Trump is even if he assesses
he has a better shot at winning with the Santurce,
Trump wants to definitely be like the Alpha as
he sees it. And Mike Pence has much more, sort of
like stereotypical beta vibes than Ron DeSantis.
I mean, this is like such stupid language.
I don't even know that this really exists. But
the way they see it, I think DeSanto is not as
good of a beta to Trump's alpha as is Mike Pence.
Now, there's nothing actually alpha about Trump,
but I'm just saying as they see it.
Speaker 4: Makes sense. Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend, thank you for
the call. All right, there is nary from Boston.